so it's great to see you here today max
how are you I'm doing well thank you
it's good
now of course we want to talk a little
about team wolf some unknown reason that
doesn't show you that you were in
squeeze right yeah no what was it like
joining that cast but it's already quite
well established wasn't it being like
kind of new kid on the block as it were
yeah it's it's actually it's it's really
nice to come into a show that's set up I
mean everything was kind of an order and
then it is it's it's like coming in like
a new kid
sophomore year or your your fourth year
in high school just there's establish
friendships everyone has what's going on
everyone's excited to work but then
you're the yeah it's you're the exciting
one so I had a great time plus I just I
just love the cast I mean we still stay
in touch even though I'm off the show
now and it was a wonderful experience
now I did have some questions as well as
my own today from your fans and friends
around the world have been twisted into
me and one of them now is from Teen Wolf
lovie and they want to know did you both
want to go into acting that senior
brother Charlie or did you influence
each other um that's a good question I
think with acting my brother and I
certainly have a flair for the dramatic
I mean if you knew us growing up we were
complete drama queens
but whatever I think my brother was
first drawn to theater I think he'd done
a play in third grade and loved it and
being twins you know something I wanted
to do I always loved cinema I loved I
wasn't really a TV watcher growing up
but I loved the old films and films that
my older brothers would give me that I
wasn't supposed to watch and and I I was
always always drawn to it but I never
really saw myself as being someone who
could do it whereas my brother went to
drama school for high school and studied
in university and so on so he kind of
dragged me into it when we were put on
Desperate Housewives together and I was
excited as hell but ultimately ecstatic
about it because it is something I've
always wanted to do and I want to
continue acting and
and get into more writing and production
direction behind the cameras very cool a
bit of an all-rounder then ya know be
good now struck by Styles wanted me to
ask you what was the toughest thing that
you have to do when you're on Teen Wolf
um I think the toughest thing about
being on Teen Wolf is since we're
werewolves we have to shoot a lot at
night so there are there are two parts
to it in terms of the werewolf thing
getting in shape for Teen Wolf
especially in the period between when we
first found out we were gonna be on the
show and then the first episode was a
nightmare
it was um we had a really good trainer
named Tony but it really is as bad as
everyone says it's uh about two times a
day up at 5:00 a.m. generally work out
lift for an hour and a half then you're
eating just like the most bland protein
like Greek yogurt ten times it's
horrible
and then you have to run for about six
to nine miles at night so it's not that
it's that bad it's just if you're not
used to it it's a big change so I was
very sore and then the other thing is
it's really fun being on set but we we
shoot a lot wish you like half an action
movie pretty much each episode is 44
minutes of all over the place stuff I
mean action drama comedy but when you
shoot a movie normally that would be
anywhere from three weeks at the very
minimum to you know even six months to
shoot a whole film and we're shooting
almost half a feature film in about
eight days so that means we're working
crazy hours sometimes fourteen sometimes
sixteen hours and sometimes I'll go
overnight so you'll start working at
5:00 p.m. until maybe 9 or 7 a.m. the
next morning
and when those starts to add up and
you're pretty tired yeah what do you do
when you finished uh you know the season
filming you just collapse oh my god I've
just been eating like pure crap last six
minutes I need to get back to the gym
but yeah when the season's over it's
generally like right around Christmas
time was when we finished so you're just
on vacation I think yeah Daniel Sharman
and I did a little bit of traveling and
just did nothing I was so excited to
just go to sleep it was
never has sleep seems like exciting oh
my god who's the best who's the best
but whatever it's worth it it was great
it seems in season three and of course
you had that big finale didn't ya I mean
what was it like filming that and what
do you think it meant for the show and
if you were character as well um well
you know when I initially read it read
the script Jeffrey pulled me aside and
like hey max any of this big smile on
his face I was like oh this means I
haven't did something really good or I'm
screwed and he said you know I want you
to read this we actually decided that
we're gonna kill your character this
season because it's what makes sense for
his arc so I was behind it immediately
like I was very excited I thought it was
a good way to finish the story and you
know in season three B we had a lot to
do with styles and a lot going on with
and again it gets me in so much so I
didn't really I don't know I I didn't
see where things were going with me
necessarily so to have that final moment
with my brother and get to kind of
redeem myself but I felt really good now
in terms of shooting it at the end of
the season as always when it starts to
stack up a little bit so that's when
that's when those long hours I was
talking about happen and I think we are
up at 7 a.m. and we had about 30 minutes
of night time left because we had to
shoot it at night because Dawn was
coming so we shot that last scene with
my brother where I died in about I want
to say 30 minutes which is insane but it
was cool I mean it really was it was a
nice way I think there's the last scene
I shot there's a nice way to say goodbye
yeah I mean I know you said a nice way
to say goodbye and you are dead so it
seems crazy devices question but
stranger things have happened
do you think you would ever go back to
the team world what do you think Charlie
would ever go back as well I mean I
always told Jeff I was open to the idea
you know the reason we left isn't
because we wanted to leave we've been
working on this other show the leftovers
for HBO and I was an amazing opportunity
to go to that and I don't know it I told
Jeff Flake don't kill me I'll come back
you know I mean and he killed me so it's
his fault but
I'm gonna leave the the the door a
little bit of jar of course I'd be
willing to go back worked out
resurrected yeah yeah that'd be badass
yeah
only kidding wasn't really dead yeah not
dead what's up I was saying since Lydia
is a banshee and can maybe you know
speak to the nether world or whatever I
can have sort of dreamlike situation
yeah like ghosts yeah it's good to be
continued
now if you could have given your
character a ton any advice what would
you said to him buffman
don't die yeah don't kill people that'd
probably be a good one too it was a
whole thing with Lydia wasn't it like
you're you're a bad guy you know you
don't just fight boy you're back guy on
you yeah but it did change didn't know
that though I was like where the hell
did this come from we've been like
hooking up for a season at this point I
all of a sudden you change your mind
today I was kind of shocked when I read
that too and I don't know I didn't think
I was a bad guy except for the whole
Boyd thing but yeah it's not my fault
you were so over that I'm over what's
done is done now if you could have spent
any more time on cat on camera with any
character he would've had liked to have
had more screen time with um you know I
kind of wanted the Alpha Pack to be
together a little bit more I felt like
we did a lot of our stuff separately and
I wanted to see more of our stories and
our individual characters like Deucalion
was a really interesting character and
Callie and I think you know if we could
have spent oh I'm so sorry if we could
have spent more time together and kind
of explored our relationships a bit more
that would have been very cool because I
always thought it was kind of I like
being villain you know and villainous
and and we were all villains but any
good villain has a really badass story
behind it so I would have loved to
explore that a little bit more and how
about if you could have faced off you
get done battle with anyone in the show
huge you've liked to had a fight with
like proper it would have been fun to
fight
Jennifer Blake yeah see you know have
those like crazy push away powers i
telekinetic powers so that would have
been interesting we did it a little bit
but uh maybe some more that or perhaps
yeah or the Argent's I remember when we
were shooting they they would shoot
paintballs and stuff at us when there
was the Argent's with like the explosive
guns and stuff that was just fun to
shoot so I'm up for that any time did
you paint Bulldog over then ya know it's
it's it's super fun because sometimes we
use explosives and I forget what they're
called off the top of my head but
they're basically paintballs with
explosives in them and they'll just say
you know alright on three we're gonna
shoot it next your head try and look
scared and then the first one goes by
you and you're instantly like what do
you mean like you're already freaking
out and but it's exhilarating so I love
doing that and when the explosives go
off and stuff it it's just a lot of fun
minutes to feel very real so no trying
needed I am very good thank you very
much now we've had a question in from
o'brosey though also known as starters
hair and I'm asked this to Holland as
well exactly great name oh this of
course to to Holland but um she this
person asked studia Australia so
shipping who and why I mean now that I'm
no longer in the picture I mean I'll go
studio no that's this class it needs to
happen no I'm coming back it's ghost
[ __ ] dolls is gross meat yeah yeah it's
done no I I hope it happens if I yeah as
a fan that's something that needs to
happen so I'll take myself out of the
picture on this speaking of Holland what
they like working with her or the other
guys as well that you work with on set I
mean it's a good time we're all we're
all the same age
and I think well you know exciting to be
there and it's just a lot of camaraderie
particularly when you know those late
nights sometimes it just feels like
summer camp because the rest of your
life is not happening you are on set but
thank goodness we all got along and
all their together because it's not so
bad you know it's it's really it's a
pleasure working with all of them and
I've learned so much from all of them as
well just both onset and offset just how
to conduct yourself and then need a
little tricks that people might have
onset in terms of acting right so I
really enjoy it's really nice working
with a big group like that and we're all
kind of we get along we hang out off
screen a team wolf Olivia wanted to know
how much the Teen Wolf cast hang out the
cast old and new oh yeah I mean for
example we're all just in Paris together
and it would have been very easy to
avoid each other if we had wanted to but
now we we we stay in touch I think a
fair amount
I see Holland and Daniel and my brother
who's a cast member I have to live with
him all the time but yeah whenever I'm
in LA I'll drop to the set to go see
Dylan or posy or all the all the crew
everyone's wonderful it really was I
think we go out of our way to see each
other which is what you get up to
between takes on sex it's a long day if
only as you say yeah I mean there were a
couple times sometimes y'all shoot early
in the morning and have this huge space
since we shoot again I think one day
Hall and I went to Target and bought
like an inflatable pool and water guns
and just sat outside and whatever you do
to pass the time there's some
motorcycles on set to like whatever you
can do to pass the time I should say
like get work done focus that's only
something welcomed some Greek yogurt oh
yeah we actually do have a gym one set
by the way yeah yeah and you'll kind of
get a wink from the producers like red
for shirtless scene or something you're
maybe looking a little out of shape had
fun on the weekend I'll just look over
you know yeah well not brutal it's good
that's good it's healthy are you glad
now that you didn't have to do so much
running in so much weight lifting you
know I actually I kind of miss it
yeah like after this Ian and I might go
play some tennis or something I feel so
out of shape I mean I've been I've just
been eating like a hog the last week so
now it feels good to be that clean like
yeah you're yeah yeah not fun to do it
but it feels good yeah it's like at
least I'm and if you could bring any
other actor into Teen Wolf he's not in
the show already who would you like to
bring in any other actor into Teen Wolf
especially I think it'd be fun to like
merge worlds with Vampire Diaries or
supernatural like I don't know I always
thought it'd be fun to have like a
hybrid show I don't watch Vampire
Diaries or supernatural side I couldn't
tell you but what actor would I bring in
I have never thought of this before I
would bring in Ian McKellen yeah let's
have a wizard on the show that'd be sick
yeah that's good that's good Gandalf
cloak and stick and home oh yeah I mean
now team of lovey and it's got another
question for you which actors would you
particularly like to work with on any
show anytime anytime um well I wish I
could go back in time I I mean my
favourites are like Paul Newman Peter
O'Toole but I've always loved like Jack
Nicholson or or Matt Damon or Tom Cruise
for different reasons but those were the
the actors I watched growing up I was
kind of enamored with so I'd love to
work with them again for for different
reasons but yeah highly respect all
those really good really good choices
that past and present now hey well done
you know and of course you've lost lots
of comments members including yourself
and Charlie from last season and the
previous eases well we lost cotton
Haynes - he went off to do arrow
superhero a show so and there's loads of
superhero TV shows now and loads more
coming up and loads of superhero movies
as well so if you would you like to do
that kind of movie and which superhero
would you like to kind of be part of
their world I mean I think it would be
very cool to do it a superhero kind of
franchise at one point right now I'd
love to do maybe some more comedy or
writing I don't know some more I'd like
to speak more I didn't speak a whole
but yeah if I had to be a superhero who
was I always interested in again
I like villains yeah I would love to
play a villain but um who I read a lot
of comics x-men was always my favorite
and I love gambit he was a really cool
character so that'd be cool
what do you think of Channing Tatum
income but he's gonna be gambit you know
yeah really I think that's good good old
selling boy that's a that's a good
choice of course you've got to talk to
you about your new show as well the left
oh yeah there's big HBO show atria have
so many fantastic shows don't they
what do you enjoy most about playing the
frost twins and that comes from Team Ida
team Ida another good question my
favorite thing about playing the frost
twins at this point has been I don't
know the show itself were so different
than the show the show is very layered
and complex and I think it deals with
with kind of a wonderful topic but
certainly a hard one to talk about which
is grief and trauma and also just look
like kind of some existential questions
and my brother and I have absolutely
zero concerns I'm down for like the
existential stuff were high or whatever
but we're just in the ping-pong and
making sure everyone's cool and like I
go on set I'm just like I have a great
time like I'm just high it's all good so
I enjoy that but in terms of series I
think it's I mean I'm honored to be a
part of it and to me every every scrap
script I read was incredibly moving and
I hope people like it because I think
it's very special very special people
want answers I think everyone wants
answers and I don't think life is
necessarily about getting answers and
you know sometimes I have to give up
having questions and just appreciating
it or investing in something and that's
how I recommend you look at this show
that's all I can say how were you over
the book that it's based on stumper
Arthur professor isn't it the leftover
yet my brother and I had actually read
it when it came out and I wouldn't okay
I read I wouldn't
myself like a great reader but I read a
fair amount and I liked the book I liked
it was very subtle and I liked how
satirical it was and I forgot that the
frost winds were even in it and my
friends started getting called in to go
audition for the pilot and and then I
was like wait that okay this is cool
they're turning it into a series I
wonder how it's gonna go and then all of
a sudden the frost winds came to me and
my brother is an opportunity and I was
like oh my god I completely forgot this
is so cool
so I was very excited now I love the
book again it's it's completely
different from the series Tom certainly
brought a huge element of that book in
the series but Damon and you know they
created something new which I also like
with eco Pittsburgh as well in directing
how are you working with him yeah Peter
Berg's awesome Peter is an actor as well
and he's he's an improvisational
director and I can't speak to his style
but it's fun to work with him because
he's very much going with the flow he's
like water and he'll hide these cameras
way back so you don't know who's on
camera and who's not and you know have
you improvised stuff so that you're just
loose and you have to be ready for
anything and as a result you know you
don't go in prepped and you're not all
serious and like I have to do this which
he does allow as well but you're just
kind of there and you're ready to play
so it was a pleasure and and yeah he'll
throw stuff that you do not expect like
Charlie and I were properly beating the
crap out of each other stuff like it's
it's a good time I enjoyed it immensely
so well cookie mentioned Damon as well
he's he's written it
what's more teeth he's done loads of
stuff they have lost star trek into
darkness prometheus in what do you think
he's brought to this particular
adaptation I mean I think Damon brings
an energy and a spirit to what he writes
particularly with the leftovers
I don't know it's it's just it's to me
it's a sense of wonder
it's kind of those those those things
that you can't necessarily articulate
but you just see them as magical a
little bit because I remember reading
these scripts and all of a sudden I just
be like oh like just one small symbol
and not reading into we're trying to
find meaning or anything but he would
just he would just create the story and
you didn't know it was going and all of
a sudden they would I don't even want to
say culminate but you'd start to see
this this thing surface and yeah it's
just really moving so he brought he
brought that that element that sort of
mystery I don't know how to describe it
I shake it articulate myself a little
better but he brought that to the show
and I think that that comes more and
more and more so yeah I mean of course
you've got great cast as well as with
yourselves you've got Christopher
Eccleston and then even if Tyler just
into room I mean what's it like working
with Christopher for example know
everyone's good-natured I mean we all
kind of have these different we have
very different storylines when we don't
we we don't really see each other a
whole lot and that way it's kind of
different than Teen Wolf which is a
bummer because everyone's cool every now
and then we'll have dinner at Carrie's
house or we'll go out and certainly some
of us I'm not well some of Jill's gang
I'll just cut leave with that we'll go
and get dinner and stuff together but
everyone I've met like Christopher
Eccleston is charming hilarious he comes
to set with a perfect American accent so
you can't tell but as soon as he's done
you're like boy he's like everyone's
great lives great I they're all so
different but I look up the each of them
so sitting down talking for a second
with Michael Gaston as well it's it's
cool I can't believe I'm a part of it
like it's it's very cool I mean what's
the potential do you think for a second
season of it you know I have no idea
again I would love to work on a second
season I don't necessarily know where
it's gonna go I think the first season
is incredible I think it's worth
sticking through all the way the ten
episodes and I really I'd love to work
on a second season
but I'm not even think about that I just
finished filming in there I'm not I'm
not thinking about it yeah but I'm still
gonna ask you that even though you know
thank you where would you like to see it
go if it did if it did a second season
I'd like to see it go
I don't want to spoil the first season
because by telling you the second season
you know what happens in the person but
uh I can't tell you where I would like
it to go for me I'd like to explore
maybe what it's like in a day for the
Frost twins I think next episode you'll
see what I mean and of course being an
HBO show there's so many big HBO shows
on this I've got to ask you about one
that's like absolutely massive at the
moment Game of Thrones have you watched
it yeah no I
I've been Game of Thrones is a lot of
fun I'm so impressed that they can pull
off such an epic story with amazing sets
and and I don't know I what I love about
Game of Thrones is it has a history
that's entirely fabricated but it's so
believable like I just want to know more
about each house and each character and
like all this stuff and I'm impressed
that the show can take a book like that
and really make it happen like you can
invest in these characters even you'll
have so many stories to tell you can
invest in the characters and see where
things go so I love I've got a throne er
as I say all the time I love that show
if you could be now you're probably a
family yeah if you could have a part in
era Thrones what kind of role would you
like you could be any character either
one that's in there at the moment will
come in and putting you on who would you
be I feel like I have to just say
something like definitely stroke cuz
that's what you say friend like I don't
know
I would love to oh we've got the
assassin storyline next year right yeah
I would totally do that in a second I
have to work on my accent but I would
totally do that yeah
what did he succeed seen all those
season for having it yeah yeah so what
did you think when oberyn martell
what were you thinking when you saw that
the mountain versus the Viper that
that's that face-off god it was shocking
wasn't it well not have you read the
votes
but even people who read the books even
book readers still was like oh my god I
can't believe like yeah I think it's
it's and this is the fun part of
filmmaking in general is like okay we
have this event we have this thing
that's happened on paper but how do we
what do we want to do with it and the
fact that you can just hold on something
or like make something that kind of
visceral yeah it's disgusting but I was
like oh yeah like I love it when you're
kind of shocked so it's cool yeah yeah
that's a good way to go and it's a
tyrant on the toilet yeah that was a
great Father's Day episode we saw that
on Mother's Day in the u.s. happy
Father's Day this is really nice
yeah we Jeffery dying as well everyone's
been night buddy and finally he fell off
his peg well he did such a great job I
don't know how old that that actor is
now but holy I'm okay holy moly yeah I
thought he was amazing so I was kind of
bummed to see him go but yeah Joffrey
Joffrey needed to go it was his time to
get Beatty thrown so yeah he was amazing
though yeah he was a truly evil little
bastard he was great he was great
Holland want me to ask you about how you
do your transformation in the show or
how you did it with your brother Charlie
into super werewolf oh god I remember
the first time we showed up to shoot our
very first transformation and I I read
it almost kind of you know I had
imagined something else and but yeah I
had to ask because we were kind of doing
the blocking I said Jeff how're how are
we gonna transform how you envisioned
this because in the script it says I
punched through his back but and I said
then he had my brother crouch over and
me I thought I was gonna be like kind of
whatever whatever it was just the most
awkward thing on set like there were a
couple stars there were a couple times
when we had our shirts off and they're
like okay for the CGI piece we need you
and your brother to fall apart I was
like okay how exactly are we gonna do
that yeah we need you to get on top of
your brother and just kind of wiggle
around a little bit and and then fall
out of him and I was like you got to be
kidding me so you just be on the ground
kind of writhing and gyrating on top of
your brother like now a little bit more
yeah okay that looks great nope okay
yeah a little bit more a little bit more
and anyways there were so many of those
that I was just like oh my god I hope
that make this work this is gonna look
ridiculous and the CGI was great like
there are some other ones where we had
to like intertwine arms and fall apart
and on the day we were just kind of like
rubbing each other's it was so weird but
uh yeah transformation I don't get to do
the makeup I just fist my brother so
it's probably the last time I'll say
that no it's all awkward it games of
Thrones ish actually isn't it it is yeah
what was cool it was cool and then and
Yahoo played us together is perfect like
well max it's been fantastic talking to
you thanks so much for your time today
and lots of lit with the leftovers
cannot wait to see where it goes ah I
think he was very nice munion as well
you